hello very good morning to you well we
start today with some breaking news as
GDP figures for November are just out
now this is the first assessment of the
economy after Rishi sunak's First full
month in office
well monthly GDP the standard measure of
the size of the economy fell by 0.6 in
September 2022 now this decline was
partly down to the additional bank
holiday for the Queen's funeral with
many businesses closed
the British economy bounced back in
October growing by 0.5 percent but this
was widely considered to be a bit of a
false Dawn and then breaking news this
morning with the office of national
statistics confirming that the UK
economy unexpectedly grew by 0.1 percent
in November
so let's get more on these latest
figures um we can bring in our
correspondent Murray Aurora now so
Murray
um 0.1 growth in these latest uh figures
and what's that unexpected
yes Anna that was massively unexpected
uh so far we kind of had a general
expectation uh was about 0.3 we were
expecting it to contract by 0.3 so this
is a really a positive outlook for the
UK economy and to an extent therefore
really to an extent we could say Rishi
sunak has been Vindicated he one of his
five pledges that he outlined just last
week was actually to grow the economy so
technically he's done that and that
obviously depends on whether he can
actually continue that throughout the
year but so far so good so I think that
will be very much light relief for the
Prime Minister today now interestingly
you know we had those stats from
previous uh months so October it grew by
0.5 but we were aware the that was seen
as you say as a bit of a false Dawn but
also in
September sorry we had that at 0.6
contraction as well and as you say we
expected that to be partly down to the
Queen's funeral and that extra bank
holiday therefore kind of throwing a
curveball in there economically but so
far I mean economists will be to an
extent quite surprised by this and
obviously pleasantly surprised by this I
think this is really really good
headlines for number 10 at the moment
they are very very concerned about their
image especially with strikes and other
political difficulties and now they can
show that they have got a grip on the
economy and Rishi sunak is the right man
for the job
yeah interesting stuff for Mario so just
remind everybody office for National
statistics with those latest figures
saying the UK economy grew by 0.1
between October and November Mari thanks
very much indeed
now A woman has died and another has
been injured in a dog attack in Surrey
with seven dogs being rounded up by
police so let's find out more about what
happens guys Shaman Freeman Powell is at
the sea now Shema this sounds like
absolutely horrendous incident what
details do we have
directly behind me that's an access road
that leads leads on to Gravelly Hill
this has been called and off now since
yesterday afternoon that's when
Emergency Services responded to calls
that a dog had been attacking members of
the public now emergency services
arrived but despite the best efforts of
paramedics sadly a woman in her 20s was
pronounced dead here at the scene now
the details of the woman in her 20s is
yet to be released to Media but the
police have said that her next of kin
have been informed and support officers
are supporting her family at this time
now the second woman was also taken to
hospital for her condition as well but
police say that her injuries are not
thought to be life-threatening now the
details surrounding exactly what
happened still remain unclear but we do
know that uh yesterday that the police
at intended here with armed officers and
the help from National Police Air
Service and they detained seven dogs who
currently remain in police custody now
the police have commented and are asking
for members of the public not to
speculate about what happened here
yesterday afternoon now in a statement
Chief Inspector Alan sproston said our
thoughts are with the family of the
woman who sadly died the incident will
be concerning to local community and I
would like to reassure them that we
believe that all dogs have been
accounted for and are in police custody
he continues by saying that our
investigation is to establish the
circumstances of the incidents and it
remains ongoing and we would ask the
community not to speculate
Siobhan thanks very much indeed
a man has been charged with the murder
of 26 year old Ellie Edwards who was
shot dead on Christmas Eve at a
merseyside pub The Beautician had been
out celebrating with friends when she
was shot she was later pronounced dead
in hospital 22 year old Connor Chapman
has also been charged with two counts of
attempted murder and will appear in
court later today the shooting also left
four men injured
Lisa Marie Presley has died aged 54. the
singer and the only child of rock and
roll legend Elvis had been taken to
hospital after suffering possible
Cardiac Arrest our U.S correspondent
Martha Kellner has the latest from Los
Angeles
Lisa Marie Presley was a very well-known
figure in Hollywood not just because she
was the daughter and the only child of
rock and roll legend Elvis she also had
marriages to Michael Jackson and
Nicholas Cage she too was the owner of
her father's Graceland property in
Memphis Tennessee which she's made into
one of America's leading tourist
attractions the first hint that we got
that something had gone terribly wrong
with her health was when Emergency
Services were called to her home in
Calabasas a suburb of Los Angeles after
she she suffered a suspected cardiac
arrest her mother Priscilla the pair
were very close then wrote on Instagram
asking people for their prayers for her
daughter but it was just a few hours
later that Priscilla Presley released a
statement I'll read that now she said
it's with a heavy heart that I must
share the devastating news that my
beautiful daughter Lisa Marie has left
us she was the most passionate strong
and loving woman I have ever known we
ask for privacy as we try to deal with
this profound loss the Presley family is
no stranger to grief or premature death
Lisa Marie was just nine years old when
her father Elvis died of a heart attack
at Graceland in
1977 and just a couple of years ago Lisa
Marie's son Benjamin died by Suicide and
she's recently wrote an essay talking
about the profound effect grief like
that has on an individual the Presley
family once again in mourning for Lisa
Marie Presley this time who's died at
the age of 54.
well there have been tributes coming in
overnight for Lisa Marie the singer Pink
issued a statement on Instagram and said
oh this one hurts my heart Lisa Marie
you were one of a kind actor John
Travolta said Lisa baby girl I'm so
sorry I'll miss you but I know I'll see
you again my love and heart goes out to
Riley Priscilla Harper and Finley
and Rita Wilson posted on behalf of
herself and her husband Tom Hanks who
starred in the recent Elvis biopic she
said our hearts are broken with a sudden
and shocking passing of Lisa Marie
Presley tonight
now a donor who bankrolled Nigel
farage's brexit party has made Boris
Johnson the number one most donated to
MP this Parliament after donating a
seven-figure sum well the former prime
minister received a single donation of
one million pounds from brexiteer and
crypto investor Christopher harborne a
former Tori donor and the donation mix
Boris Johnson the MP who's received the
most through donations a total in excess
of 1.2 million pounds
well our political correspondent Rappel
is here with me a very good morning to
you rob good to see you
um so it's a lot of money isn't it does
it tell us anything about Boris
Johnson's political future do you think
I think you could probably read into it
that he's not planning on going anywhere
I think this is probably to my mind
anyway the largest single political
donation any MP has ever had as you say
it came from Christopher harborne he's
someone who is an investor in the tech
industry deals in cryptocurrency and
things like that
um and uh he previously as you say is
there has donated to the brexit party to
Nigel farage so clearly is a big um
brexiteer there now these donations are
usually spent on things like office
costs and Staffing and campaigning
former Prime Ministers already get an
allowance to run things like
administrative
um spend and office costs so precisely
what he's going to spend this on I think
is probably a fair question this came in
the latest registers of interest that
was published where MPS have to declare
things like this there was also
information in there about more speeches
he was giving we already know the former
prime ministers and hundreds of
thousands of pounds from giving speeches
across the world he's also being living
rent free in a home owned by the JCB
chairman um as well that's been declared
um on there so as I say I think what can
you read into this well I don't think
Boris Johnson is going to slip away Into
Obscurity anytime soon that's perhaps
backed up by a story that we're running
this morning as well friends of Boris
Johnson allies have told Sky News that
potentially if he was offered a safe
seat to stand in in the next election
then he might sort of call off the dogs
if you like on Rishi sunak or not
challenge him in the near future
especially if there are disappointing
results in the May leadership look I
think a lot of MPS when you ask about
the prospects of a Boris Johnson
comeback would sort of raise a quizzical
eyebrow if you like because clearly he
is a divisive figure within the party
this shows that there is still there are
still a kind of rump of MPS that believe
he could come back want him to come back
many will be fiercely in the opposite
camp and the other thing about this
story is that whilst I think allies will
say this comes from a position of
strength that they are saying he may
well be able to challenge Rishi sunak
for the top job actually it sort of
comes from a position of weakness
because it's a tacit acknowledgment that
he is sitting on quite a small majority
in his West London seat and he may well
lose it in the next election yeah
interesting and of course Richie sunac
meanwhile has set out these five pledges
hasn't he for people to judge him on
three of them actually relate to the
economy one specifically about economic
growth and we have just had the latest
growth figures out which surprised
economists they had thought it would
show a slight fall it's actually shown a
very slight rise he'll be welcoming that
yeah you imagine number 10 will jump on
that
um I think in terms of his promises we
will have to wait over the longer term
and get some of the quarterly data so
that will come out next month before we
can really start to take a full picture
of where the economy is going and I
think it will take longer into the new
year to make a judgment on that as well
also when you read into the release from
the office of national statistics into
sort of the breakdown of what lies
behind this 0.1 growth in November
um it talks about how a large part of it
came down from a 0.4 percent increase in
output from consumer facing services
that was majorly driven by uh growth
from food and beverage service
activities in a month where the FIFA
World Cup started so clearly some of
this is being driven by more people
going to the pub to watch the football
more people going out and using pubs and
restaurants and things like that so how
much it can be tied up I guess with
Rishi sunax handling of the economy and
political approach is debatable yeah
interesting and we are talking to to an
economist a little bit later so they'll
dig into the fields too everyone thanks
very much indeed
no Ukraine has says its troops were
holding out against pro-moscow forces in
the Eastern salt mining town of Soledad
more than 500 civilians including
children are said to be trapped there
Russia's Wagner group run by an ally of
President Vladimir Putin claimed to have
taken solidar meanwhile Western
countries have started to offer Kiev
Advanced weaponry
Poland has confirmed plans to send more
than a dozen tanks to Ukraine Kiev will
be equipped with Leopard 2 and
Challenger tanks the move represents a
significant Step Up in Western support
yesterday the Ukrainian ambassador to
the UK Vadim prosthaico was on the show
and told us his country needed many more
tanks from its NATO allies we near
thousands that's for sure because
Russians are put in thousands of tanks
in front of our lines we have many of
ours but we need something better than
we can come up right now with the old
soviet-style not that bad but still
outdated so the challengers the Abrams
the leopards which are in abundance in
Europe this is the way to go when NATO
countries start to give you military
hardware on that level does that ratchet
up
um the situation I believe it's a bit
too late to talk about the crossing some
red lines there's so many of them being
already crossed and the sickest one was
Ukrainian border between Russia and
Ukraine so let's leave it also already
too late we have to do whatever we can
to you know to reduce the suffering on
both sides and just finish up the work
well our International correspondent
Alex Rossi has this report from solidar
this is one of the fiercest fights in
this war
armored vehicles careering back and
forth to the front line along snowy
roads to lay down fire
the sky over solidar is clouded with
smoke
and the ground shakes with the incessant
thud of artillery
in Hidden positions on the outskirts
Ukrainian drone operators gather
intelligence as shells whistle over
heads
foreign
the soldiers here deny that Russia has
captured the town
um
the drones are helping them Target
Russia's advancing Infantry
he shows us new footage the image is
grainy but you can make out a soldier
dragging an injured comrade to safety
but nowhere is safe here with both sides
taking heavy casualties
hear the sound of machine gun fire in
the distance
we are literally at the entrance to
solidar you can see the salt mine over
there where
Smoke on the horizon
now the villagers here mostly deserted
people have either left or are trying to
escape some are stay
but one thing's clear is that the
fighting remains incredibly intense
this wall is unrelentingly grim the
shell-shot civilians Stuck in the Middle
exist in constant Danger
and there's not much hope as the front
line moves closer
resolution
at the hospital in kramatosk some of the
injured from the front arrived for
emergency treatment
many have serious injuries they're often
engaging with their enemy at distances
of just 30 meters it's close combat we
have gunshots yeah we have a grenade
shrapnel wounds and so on so
this kind of wounds increased
Russian forces have though taken much of
the town and if they do win here it will
be the first victory for Vladimir
Putin's forces in months after many
military setbacks but it has come at an
enormous cost Alex Rossi Sky News on the
outskirts of solidar
let's just bring you a little a quick
response from the chancellor to those
latest growth figures that we brought
you at the top of the hour the figures
that show that the economy grew by 0.1
in November and the chancellor has
responded in the last few moments saying
we have a clear plan to half of
inflation this year he says this is an
Insidious hidden tax which has led to
hikes and interest rates and mortgage
costs holding back growth here and
around the world and Jeremy Hunt goes on
to say to support families through this
tough patch we will provide an average
of 3 500 pounds support for every
household over the Sierra next but the
most important help we can give is the
stick to the plan to halve inflation
this year so that we can get the economy
growing so Jeremy Hunt there responding
to those growth figures and saying they
do have a plan and that is to tackle
inflation and with that they hope growth
will come
now let me just let you know what's
coming up on the show in the next few
moments I will be speaking to the former
Diplomat a NATO official as Vladimir
Putin replaces his Ukraine War Commander
also ahead I'll be speaking to the head
of payments at the post office which is
urging people to use prepayment meters
to claim the government's Energy
discount
and then after eight we'll assess this
morning's GDP figures a bit further with
the economist and former bank of England
official Andrew sentence
but first some other news and millions
more people with a future risk of heart
attack and stroke could be given the
choice to take statins under new
guidelines latest evidence from the
National Institute for Health and Care
Excellence on the safety profile of
statins suggests that more people could
benefit from the cholesterol lowering
and clot busting drug
a suspect has been charged with murder
for the assassination of Japan's former
prime minister Shinzo Abe
Japanese prosecutors have formally
charged tetsuo yamagami it's believed he
shot the former leader with a homemade
gun during a campaign speech in July
outside a train station in Western Japan
a special counsel has been appointed to
investigate the discovery of classified
documents in U.S President Joe Biden's
home and former Washington office U.S
attorney general Merrick Garland
announced that Robert Herr the former
Trump appointed U.S attorney for the
District of Maryland will lead that
investigation
now then I'm joined Now by The Shadow
Northern Ireland secretary Peter Kyle um
Peter Carl very good morning to you lots
to talk to you about this morning and
but I wonder if we could kick off with
your reaction to the latest growth
figures that were announced at seven
o'clock this morning showing that the
economy grew by 0.1 in November a sign
that things are improving
well a sign of basically effectively no
growth actually isn't a sign of success
for our economy what we need to be doing
is having a much more fundamental
rethink about how our economy is being
run link it to the industrial action at
the moment link it to the failure in
public services when you have seven
million people waiting for treatment on
the AHS that is seven million people who
are unable to fully engage in the
economy in work uh who will be taking
time off six so it's not just about the
fundamentals of direct economic policy
that we need to look at it is the
running of our public services in our
country which is which is preventing us
from fully exploring our potential as a
country and individuals out there in the
economy these are the things we need to
get right in order to get real growth
into the economy going forward and of
course labor has its plan for the green
posterity fund and also
completely reforming business rates so
that small businesses can get
turbocharged we want to do that from day
one of a labor government
okay and let's talk about public
services then the running of them and
the NHS in particular because the
guardian is reporting this morning that
the health secretary Steve Barkley is
privately conceding that uh he'll have
to increase the payoff to NHS staff are
you pleased to hear that
what I'm pleased to hear is that finally
far far far too late because all of this
could be done could have been done
before industrial action actually
impacted our public services so
profoundly that ministers are willing to
engage open-heartedly in negotiations
which is what I hope this is signaling I
don't know that for a fact but I hope
this is signaling Steve Barkley and
other ministers need to get into the
room and actually start having things on
the table for negotiation now you know I
when I was being interviewed by by you
some time ago I was being asked is is 19
acceptable and then suddenly you know
the nurses offer is halved over a period
of a couple of weeks of course so
everyone has things on the table they go
into negotiations with except the
government so other other factors the
unions seem to be moving uh seem to be
willing to actually engage in and make
concessions the question is is the
government and there's nothing that the
government is is going to do or likely
to do or could do in the coming weeks
that it couldn't have done this time
last year and averted all of the this
industrial action
I'm not going to ask you again what kind
of a pay rise you think that nurses will
get because I'm pretty sure you won't
answer the question but where should the
money come from from a pay rise for
nurses should the treasury make more
money available or should it come from
existing budgets
these are all things that government are
going to have to do and governments do
all the time in the last 13 years of the
labor government from 1997 to 2010 we
had no widespread industrial action
because we manage these factors within
the government now sometimes it will
have to come from treasury other times
it will have to come from within
departmental budgets but also when you
get the government the government
departments running functionally these
things are managed and they're baked in
years in advance the negotiations that
we were having in government within with
the trade unions in our Public Services
we're talking about pay quite some time
in advance you know sometimes years in
advance so that these things were all
baked in from the very best start when
the negotiations between departments and
the treasury were taking place so when
it's done functionally it avoids the
kind of situation we're having at the
moment things have become so
dysfunctional in this in this government
that actually we're lurching from one
situation to another day to day so what
we need to do is get back to competent
management of our government of our
departments and our Public Services only
then will we avoid this sort of lurching
from side to side
but we are where we are given that
should the money come from treasury or
should it come from existing budgets
because the fear then is that that could
affect Frontline Services what's your
view well my view is I can't speak on
behalf of every government department
for the position of opposition and I'm
sure labor would do in this position if
you were to take power now
well when we do take power we all have
to take a good look at the finances
don't forget we've had four budgets in
the last year four chancellors in the
last year we don't know how many more
we're going to have before the next
election and how much more damage is
done to our public services and our
economy before we take office hopefully
we will take office so we can start
taking those vital steps forward but we
will make these decisions at the time of
taking office right now the government
has to make that decision there are a
lot of financial issues within our the
way our government is running our public
services so ministers are going to have
to do what they do not only they're
going to negotiate with the unions about
their Workforce they're going to have to
step up and negotiate on behalf of their
work for us in their departments and
their public services with the treasury
that's the way it always works
okay I want to move on to talk about
Northern Ireland you're there in Belfast
at the moment and Leo varaka the Irish
Prime Minister he said he's hopeful that
an agreement can be reached between the
EU and the UK on the Northern Ireland
protocol I know that uh labor leader to
kirstama is theirs been holding meetings
with the Irish Prime Minister and
foreign minister so how hopeful are you
actually we are there are signs of Hope
and we are not going to play politics
with this we're not going to have normal
tribal Politics on an issue so important
to the future of Northern Ireland and
the restoration of devolved uh the old
Authority here and evolved government we
must get up and running so we will be an
active partner with government and
whoever else needs to be in order to get
something across the line so there are
signs we hear of uh movement between the
UK government and the EU and that should
be celebrated whether it is enough to
actually assage all of the challenges
which the dup have uh raised well we'll
have to see because there's very little
detail coming out of these negotiations
sometimes I understand that but actually
when it comes to the individual Party
leaders here in Borden Island I think
they should have been a bit more in the
room when and a bit more informed on the
progress of negotiations and certainly
the things that the government are
aspiring to negotiate in these really
difficult negotiations but once again
there's been very little negotiation in
the last year in the run-up to elections
last year in Northern Ireland they
paused negotiations with the EU and then
when all of the difficulties within the
Tory party unfolded the the change of
three prime ministers all the
negotiations stopped so we've had over a
year or almost a year now with no
devolved Authority here in Northern
Ireland this could have been sold with
negotiations in a functional way perhaps
18 months ago and we could have avoided
this situation in the first place
I just want to ask you a quick question
on Skye's new project in conjunction
with tortoise media Westminster accounts
where we try to improve transparency for
the public so they can see what kind of
donations gifts and payments and other
benefits that MPS receive we can take a
look at your entry your donations show
nothing out of the ordinary but let's
just show people anyway do you welcome
this tool that offers transparency to
the public do you think that it's a good
step forward
I I look I really uh welcome any
transparency in politics uh particularly
when it comes to funding people do have
to understand that what I'm Keen to
explain and express is that each and
each individual MP executes their jobs
in very very different ways and
sometimes are the way we're funded and
the expenses we claim differ based on
whether we have a family or not they're
based on the distance we have to travel
to get to Parliament each week so I'm
very mindful when I with the decisions
that I take as being an MP will be
different from others and I just hope
that people will engage in conversations
if with your own local MPS about the way
they do their job before you come to any
conclusion so for example when you look
at the donations that I've made I I had
to seek those donations which is quite a
lot of money because I want to have a
very big presence on the High Street uh
in Hove and I have a shop on the High
Street and and parliamentary expenses
only cover about 35 to 40 percent of the
running of my operation so I have to
raise the money through donations to
keep that doing that's because I aspire
to do the job in a certain way and be
very very accessible to constituents and
residents and anybody else that wants to
walk in and actually you know raise
issues with me and seek help from me as
an MP and just get things onto my radar
so to do that I have to raise money so
I'm really pleased that people can look
at the donations in a very simple and
straightforward way that I get and then
I'm always here to explain why I have to
seek those donations and what I do with
those donations once I have them
okay well Peter Carr we appreciate your
time thanks for joining us there in
Belfast thank you thanks
and just to let you know that's the QR
code on your screen now that you can use
to use our Search tool and discover how
much money that your MP receives uh it's
all in the Westminster accounts from Sky
News and tortoise media
time that's a quick look at the
morning's front pages and the guardian
has an exclusive as I was talking to
Peter Kyle about there reporting that
the health secretary Steve Barkley has
privately acknowledged the government
will need to increase its payoffer to
nurses they say
the mirror also leads with an exclusive
their headline Heroes cancer treatment
as a number of firefighters at grenfell
have since been diagnosed with cancer in
some cases terminal
The Daily Telegraph understands that
government intends to ban gas boilers in
the next 10 years in a push for Net Zero
and the eye leads with research showing
that 34 homeless children in England
died over a three-year period
and are there at some of the morning's
front pages for you now more than 50
flood warnings have been issued across
the UK mostly in the west and the
Southwest parts of Wales have suffered
power cuts and blocked railway lines and
more bad weather is on the way well
Heavy Rain continues to fall submerging
roads and putting Homes at risk the Met
Office has issued a yellow rain warning
with some Southwestern areas already
having had more than 80 millimeters of
rainfall
or trees can play an important role in
preventing flooding a new study by
Forest research found that woodlands in
Scotland can save up to 100 million
pounds in flooding damages by soaking up
excess rain water quantifying this
sponge effect helps authorities better
understand the true value of trees in
reducing flooding
And You And scientists have confirmed
that the past eight years were the
hottest eight on record globally so
let's get more on this with our Sky
meteorologist Steph gulter so a step
quite a shocking fact that isn't it but
perhaps not surprising giving all the
warnings that that our planet's heating
up
that's right I mean we already heard
that for the UK 2022 was the hottest on
record but now we're hearing that
globally it's around the fifth or sixth
hottest on record so we're still right
up there and the last eight were the
eight hottest so it's not like this is
an anomaly this is just a continuation
and actually
um compared to recent years uh we've all
been very very warm it's not the hottest
though because we generally have some
natural variability in there as well so
what's happening in the oceans or what's
happening maybe there's a volcanic
eruption one of the biggest influences
we have is what's happening in the
Pacific Oceans whether you have La Nina
which is a cooling of the surface waters
or El Nino which is a warming so 2016
which was the hottest year globally on
record that was an El Nino year not
really a surprise and then for La Nina
that's what we've got at the moment and
have had for the last two years as well
so it could be that this coming year
because we're expecting La Nina to ease
it could be that this this year's even
hotter
okay Steph fascinating thanks very much
indeed for that
so let's take a look then at the weather
now shall we
had warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
well the weather stays unsettled over
the weekend but it turns colder with the
risk of some ice snow and strong winds
there's a mixed start to the day with
clouds and showers along with some clear
spells strong overnight winds will ease
slowly but it will be a bit of a brief
respite
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
well with parts of the world
experiencing extreme weather conditions
let's take a look now at the impact of
climate change on the planet and just to
show you here on our data dashboard the
the right hand side of the screen shows
how the UK's power is currently being
produced at nearly 11 there from gas for
example 66 from Renewables on the top
left you can see how much warmer the
Earth is now than in 1880 that's around
the time of the Industrial Revolution
when modern records keeping began and at
the bottom the total amount of CO2
emissions there in millions of tons
now do say with us coming up on Sky News
breakfast I'll be speaking to you a
former Diplomat a NATO official as
Vladimir Putin replaces his Ukraine War
Commander of the battle for a key mining
town rages on
[Music]
a military shake-up Vladimir Putin has
sacked top Ukraine Commander Sergey
sorovicin after just three months and
instead replaced him with Chief of
general staff Valerie garasimov well
joining me now is former Diplomat and
former NATO official Robert pachelle
thanks very much indeed for joining us
here this morning first of all I
wondered if you could comment on what's
going on on the ground heavy fighting in
solidar as we've been reporting this
morning
why is this town such a focus is it
strategically important
yeah good morning well it has of course
like everything that's happening on that
particular part of the front of of
importance because you know you know
taking a town leads to uh you know it
leads to a certain initiative if you
like on the front but I I don't think I
would use the word strategic it is
however important from the point of view
of Moscow uh and particularly those who
are
um you know on the main uh you know uh
are leading this unsold which is the
Wagner group rather than the armed
forces the military per se because they
want desperately to show some kind of
success you know hence you see this you
know essentially scorched policy and
something which not just ukrainians
describe as you know making some slow
advances on essentially the corpses of
the people uh that they are sent forward
I mean this is this is really almost
like a suicidal type of a of an attack
so no I don't think it's strategic uh
but it is politically as I said
important both for the Kremlin and for
the people like pregoing the head of the
Wagner group to show that you can score
some success because success has been
secretly I mean has been has been
lacking uh for for Moscow for many
months
we've learned that Britain and Poland
are confirming that they're planning to
send more tanks to Ukraine Britain is
sending 12 Poland is sending a company
thought to be about 14 then how much
difference could that make on the ground
given the fact that the Ukrainian
ambassador to the UK told us on this
program that thousands were needed
well you know let's be let's be honest
you know I mean every every bit helps uh
but of course particularly when we talk
about the law parts that uh a German
produced tanks that uh pollens together
with about you know I think 10 other
countries in Europe possesses uh they uh
you know if they if uh particular supply
for one country is part of bigger batch
and there are
um you know there is essentially more
than two and a half thousand available
of such tanks many of them could be
without undermining the security of the
uh many NATO countries could be
um sent to Ukraine uh that of course
would would be of immense help and one
also has to look at it from if you like
a political uh Dynamics point of view
because you know one of the biggest
problems right now is not so much the
availability of those tanks uh you know
uh more than western-made tanks but but
uh you need a decision first of all of
German money that it's okay to send them
and of course one expects Germany and
other countries to join what is
described as a kind of Coalition so
those decisions by London and also or
pledges are important because they're
moving the process forward and of course
that comes together with many other uh
important
um you know uh supplies that are
critical you know such as you know
defense systems such as Bradley's uh and
and and other types of equipment that
have been uh promised uh by you know us
France and other countries uh and that's
uh that's also if you if you want to it
you know a ammunition and and
intelligence and so on that is by far
the most important support uh the
Western Coalition the Western countries
can provide to Ukraine and Ukraine needs
this support even if it's you know if
it's doing uh well in in in terms of you
know uh standing after the Russian
Onslaught the Russia not doing very well
but of course the disparities between
the potential of Russia and Ukraine are
still there and they have to be they
have to be minimized that's that's
essentially the West's role sorry to cut
in but we're running out of time a very
quick thought on why you think President
Putin has changed his top commander in
Ukraine and what that might change on
the ground
I think there are two main reasons one
is you know they they are thinking an
agreement about big offensive and about
you know uh making sort of more uh you
know more uh more more complex if you
like static more complex operation but
there's a question mark whether this is
possible so putting the chief of uh
defense in charge makes kind of sense
but the second issue is it's about
infighting within the credit and all
those groups I mentioned Wagner there's
other National Guards and all those
people are striving you know to gain
more influence so the military are for
example not happy with uh the the
private companies having this and this
is so it's they they're fighting for you
for like the year uh of of the Tsar but
it's not clear at all whether this will
actually change the Dynamics whether
this will be affected because Russia is
not really a country well managed and
that that concerns the Armed Forces as
well of Robert Purcell fascinating to
get your take on it thanks so much for
your time this morning we do appreciate
it
thank you
now the post office is issuing an urgent
warning to households who use a
prepayment meter to ensure that they
access the tailored government support
that's available to them well I'm joined
now by the head of payment for the Post
Office Andrew Goddard money to you
Andrew Goddard so you want to draw
attention to the support that people on
prepayment meters are entitled to so
remind us what that support is and how
they get it
yes good morning
essentially customers have been
receiving vouchers uh since October so
the 400 pounds that has been divided
over six months customers have been
receiving vouchers in the post
prepayment customers if you're on Direct
debit you'll have already had that money
credited into your account
but if you're on a prepayment meter app
you will have received vouchers from
October we issue about 1.3 million every
month
and 20 of those are still to be redeemed
so it's about 17 million pounds worth of
energy is still to be redeemed
so there's a lot of people out there who
haven't claimed it how long have they
got how do they get access to it
well they've been uh receiving those in
the postal by email
every month like I said and
the what the customers need to do is
take those vouchers to their local post
office with a form of ID and proof of
address and the staff in the post office
will then redeem that against their
energy key and cars
and there's a deadline isn't there I
think it's is it January the 14th that's
the last yeah there is
yeah we've been urging customers to to
go into post offices this week
um as I said they they do expire now
there'll be some customers who may not
have received it and then with the
address details might not be correct
um or they've just mislaid that voucher
and what we do is encourage those
customers
to immediately make contact with their
Energy company
who will then have a voucher reissued
through us so that they can then go and
redeem them in the post office
yeah and as you say of 17 million pounds
still unclaimed from October support so
a lot of people out there perhaps do
need to check their vouchers and come
forward I wonder what your thoughts are
on prepayment meters I noticed yesterday
that citizens advice said that an
estimated 3.2 million people across
Britain ran out of credit on their
prepayment last year just because they
couldn't afford to top it up I mean
that's more people in 2022 they say than
the whole of the last 10 years combined
what do you make of that
yes I mean it's um you know prepayment
meters have been around for a very very
long time it's the way the energy
companies work with certain customers
they may not have the credit worthiness
to be able to pay in their ears
and obviously with the cost of living
crisis that sort of accentuates it so it
it you know these are the most
vulnerable customers in society so in
many respects what we've been trying to
do is make sure that we can get this
additional support from the government
so that they can help with the cost of
living crisis
well yes and citizens advice also said
it had seen evidence of suppliers
forcing people on to prepayment meters
after they'd racked up dead what are
your thoughts on that
yeah I mean that look I mean that that
is very much a decision by the energy
companies it's not something the post
office is directly involved in you know
our our goal as as with the post office
is to really help those customers across
our 11 and a half thousand Network to
really you know make sure that customers
have avoid the means of topping up keep
the lives on and obviously at home so
it's it's not a great situation to be in
absolutely
no and today of course you're here to
try to make sure that people get the
support that they're in entitled to but
I wondered if you had any thoughts on
the recent Royal Mail strikes that we've
been experiencing here what kind of
impact do they have on the post office
well I mean it's going to be you know
for customers who are trying to post
internationally I mean it's going to
have a major impact you know it's
something that we're monitoring
um raw male we know working incredibly
hard to restore services
the the parcel Force worldwide is still
operating so if customers are still
wanting to use parcel Force
they can come into our Branch Network
and that's operating as normal we're
obviously monitoring our system so we're
on high alert as a result of the
ransomware that you've been reporting in
the news
well yes and just a finally last
question one last appeal for you to
anybody on a prepayment meter just
remind everybody what you're asking this
morning
please do get in contact with your
energy energy company if you don't have
that October voucher please get in
contact with your Energy company today
um if you do have a voucher go down to
the local post office and redeem that
bring your ID and the money will be
credited onto your account straight away
okay all really useful information
Andrew Goddard head of payment to the
post office we really appreciate your
time this morning thanks so much thank
you
now time for a quick bit of news before
the end of the hour and at least six
people have died in Alabama and another
in Georgia after a powerful storm swept
through the Southern United States
causing tornadoes you can see some of
the pictures of the debris there
officials have reported significant
damage to properties with up to 50 homes
destroyed at least a further 12 people
have also been taken to hospital those
pictures really given an idea of some of
the damage being done